okay DJ whoo kid your your your you can
see your underpants through your through
your pants you can see your you can see
our undershorts when you bend over your
trousers don't fit properly it's a
little embarrassing there they're
hanging below your your you're in shape
your buttocks are showing over your
slacks that's not that's not Godfrey
that's Gilbert Godfried that's it's a
different guy he's g-unit or Jew you
know that's right that's right
have you met you've never met DJ no but
I wish I could talk like that yeah with
some words you guys probably say that
are alike I had you on my show before
you were on Eminem's channel interview
like years ago too did you
yeah it was I think as my ex wife was
Japanese and I had you on there walling
out we were like trying to do you miss
her get her assassinated huh last year I
really a couple years ago around
Christmastime DJ whoo kid went on the
radio and announced that he had just
given his ex-wife a pair of Yeezys for
Christmas and then announced where she
John's case anybody wanted to hit her
with a car instead like a fifteen
hundred thousand and usually Elevens are
like I thinking like three four hundred
right right right but she's got the
smaller one so if you need them and like
at least four people call up and to find
out her location really she's still
alive why God kids just get her out of
here you've been praying for that that's
the only thing I want this year for 2020
I just want her to just die do you guys
hate each other well he wants her to die
this year well I mean is it mutual or is
it you just hate her
yeah she hates me too but whatever were
you a good husband and I was teen like
crazy how did she know besides listening
to the radio
I think that's true if I remember
correctly even when you were married I
would have you on my show you guys and
like didn't help why did I say are you
happily married and you would announce
no I did cheat on her see that your
first verse said go in front of millions
of people and saying oh I cheat on my
wife
generally doesn't work she started to
get the hint something say she that's
when they start to suspect when you
admit on the radio but you know what it
is Gilbert I was always salmon Orion and
I didn't know that millions was tuned in
and then the lawyer had you guys as
Exhibit C you didn't know you were
talking into a microphone a little
nightmare well you're not a technology
guy you know sometimes you don't know
these yeah that's that a pager at a
Bieber back then right great but I had a
divorce thing kind of like woke me up so
you were on there going oh it's the
radio no one listens to that was because
I added that I came in a girl and
watched like seeming like come out her
[ __ ] we keep playing the clip Lukey do
you mean literally yes and I did admit
to you guys that I do finger her instead
of sex so that didn't help either your
your wife time yeah cuz if you can see
one arm is bigger than the you know my
own that your fingering arm
well my right arm is bigger than the
left I'm fingering yes so when you have
two it's [ __ ] serious why don't you
have some [ __ ] anymore no was it
driver old car I see I see I go so far
there's no incriminating evidence
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM Avenue